So to summarize the facilities of the
perimeters available in the spring system. Object
orientation, object technology permeates the entire operating
system design. Its used as a system structuring
mechanism in constructing a network operating system.
To break it down, in the spring system
you have the nucleus which provides you
threads. And IPC among threads. And the microkernel
prescription of lead k is accomplished by the combination of nucleus, plus the
address space management that is part
of the Spring System's kernel boundary. And
everything else lives above. This kernel,
meaning all the services you normally associate
with an operating system such as file system, network communication and so on,
were all provided as objects that live outside of this kernel. And the way you
access those objects is through doors. And in every domain there is a door table
that has a set of capabilities that
a partiuclar domain has for accessing doors on
different domains. And this door and door table
is the the basis for cross domain calls.
And through the object orientation, and through the network proxies you can have
object invocation implemented as protected procedure
calls both on the same node and
across machines. And finally, it does
virtual memory management by providing certain basic
parameters, such as the linear address space,
the memory object, external pages, and cached
object representation. Now to contrast this to Tornado. In Tornado also we saw
that it was using object technology, but the contrast is pretty distinct. In
Tornado it uses clustered object as
an optimization for implementing services. For example,
weather a particular object is singleton representation,
or it has multiple representation for each
processor, etc. Those are the kinds
of optimizations that are being accomplished using
the clustered object in the Tornado system.
Whereas in the Spring system, object technology
permeates the entire operating system design in that it is used as a system
structuring mechanism, not as just an optimization
mechanism. In constructing a network operating system.